Southwest Airlines melting down
in the wake of the Christmas
holiday.
One of the worst airline meltdowns.
Travel nightmare.
Unprecedented.
Chaos.
It's crazy.
When Southwest Airlines underwent a
historic meltdown during the
Christmas travel season and canceled
nearly 17,000 flights,
politicians pounced like passengers
on a second bag of free peanuts.
Well, they need to take care of
their passengers and they need to
take care of their employees.
It's an unacceptable situation.
But what about the FAA?
When its Notice to Air Mission
system, which gives pilots
information about flights, crashed
due to a corrupted file,
the agency halted all domestic
air travel, triggering 1,700
cancellations and 9,000
delays that screwed up air travel
for days.
Secretary Buttigieg has pledged to
get to the bottom of it all and
update the system with the single
mindedness of a TSA agent
confiscating your toenail clippers.
We'll be approaching Congress,
indicating the resources and
strategy that we think we need for
the next five years to make sure
that FAA has everything that they
need in terms of systems, resources
and staff.
Don't expect much to happen any time
soon. Minnesota Congressman
Pete Stauber introduced legislation
to modernize the Notice to Air
Mission system in 2019
and 2021, but it
ultimately went nowhere.
And when it comes to the air-traffic
control system that actually governs
all takeoffs and landings, the
FAA is about two decades
behind other countries when
it comes to directing air traffic.
Back in 2009,
Reason produced a video about how
Canada and other countries
had privatized air-traffic control
and saw delays decrease
in safety increase.
Canadians allowed Nav Canada,
a private company, to manage
their skies.
So the next time your plane is
delayed, think about why you're
stuck.
Maybe it's because of the weather
or maybe it's because of politics.
What would actually produce safer,
cheaper and less disrupted air
travel? More deregulation.
Inflation adjusted ticket prices
declined 60% between
1980 and 2020, which
explains how air travel went from
something only businessmen and the
wealthy did to a common practice.
But too many aspects of air travel
remain under government's inept
and stuck-in-the-past control.
Foreign owned airlines are blocked
from competing with domestic
carriers in the name of national
security.
The number, placement and operation
of airports are controlled by
various levels of government,
leading to insane monopolies
and fewer flight options in
places such as Atlanta, Denver and
Vegas.
Even in today's less-than-free
market, Southwest will have to
fight like hell to win back
customers by keeping prices low
and performance high.
The FAA and the government
more generally doesn't face
the same pressure.
We'll see which one fixes
its problems before the next
Christmas travel season.